the oscars really want
us
i'm trying to keep it together i'm like
you got it
you
the uh-huh
[Music]
i was driving in rush hour traffic on
the 101
and i got a call um packer actually
called us and said hey like
you're about to actually present
trophies at the academy and i was like
oh snap and basically they're looking
into you and josh to be presenters at
the oscars
i was like
i was like stop lying i have to finish
packing like what are you talking about
she's i'm like oh she's serious like so
the oscars really want
us i'm trying to keep it together i'm
like
you got it
you
the uh-huh and i finally got off on an
exit and i pulled over and again i tried
to play it cool i was like yeah no it's
totally fine but i was like what the
hell's happening and people like driving
by me and going around me and it feels
like it's a dream it feels like it's not
actually real or that i'm gonna wake up
at some point you know once you guys
actually explained you know what a
trophy presenter was then i was like oh
so like you get to go on stage and
actually you know give the trophies to
the people i've been to many an award
ceremony but this is the the mother of
all award ceremonies so i'm excited to
just be present
and just sort of like take it all in
have opportunity to just be in the same
presence of the people i look up to like
role models being able to just see them
on the professor's side it's very cool
because i get to watch
how things are put together it's
information i can share with my students
it has an upside on that because at the
end of the day the only reason i'll
mention this to students is to help them
make something i think i think that it's
going to be exciting for my students to
just at the very least and especially
you know my marginalized students to see
somebody up there and have a direct
connection to something that's felt so
mystical and so
far out of reach i watched the oscars
growing up in the past couple of years
a lot of mexican directors have been
nominated and awarded and the oscars and
it's really such an honor um watching
them
be on stage and
just
seeing myself with that possibility of
being on that stage as well i think now
more than ever this is the
most inclusion that i've seen at the
oscars and i'm loving it this was just a
blessing to to be able to go to the
oscars but let alone go to the oscars by
actually presenting awards present
trophies to people that are in the
movies that i watch and for the people i
look up to
[Music]